we understand that it is one
nine-year-old girl who was killed and
two women there are a number of injuries
at least 14. many of whom have required
hospital treatment it clearly landed in
a residential area you can see some of
the damage behind with actual homes
being hit by debris we understand
according to the mayor of Kiev Vitale
klitschklo he says this was the debris
of a missile strike which was
intercepted by the Ukrainian air defense
system you can see it's it appears very
much a residential area so apart from
the homes you've got playgrounds where
some of the debris has fallen and right
over in this corner you've got a
children's clinic we've been hearing
over the past few days that and weeks
indeed that there's been a number of
several hundred Hospital facilities T's
and Children's Clinic which which have
been hit during the course of this has
long protracted war and that is building
up towards a case which the ukrainians
are hope hoping to put forward to the
international criminal court but the
last few days the best part of the week
Kiev has woken up to sirens and
attempted missile strikes mostly being
entered 90 of them being intercepted by
their air defense systems and it was
like that this morning again the three
o'clock in the morning residents woken
up terrified
being killed and injured and that has
been the ongoing situation over the past
few days as more and more
publicity is surrounding the start of
the the counter-offensive I was talking
to someone from the Atlantic Council
this morning a former U.S ambassador who
was urging the European politicians and
the Americans to speed up their supply
of heavy weaponry and as we know
president zelinski has been making this
Whistle Stop European tour trying to
push all his Partners to come forward
more quickly with happy weapon Weaponry
like The Talented to do tanks we're
hearing that after his visit with prime
minister Rishi sunak the British have
doubled their pledge of Challenger 2
tanks and are trying to push their
European Partners to supply and quickly
Supply those F-16 Jets and that I think
has prompted this increased rhetoric
particularly against against Britain
with threats made by Dimitri Medvedev
the former president pushing saying that
they are basically Eternal enemies of
Russia and suggesting that they could be
British officials could be legitimate
military targets and that will enrage
most of the European politicians
particularly the British I imagine